u.s officials confirms 130 incidents of
mysterious havana syndrome brand if we
can flip it so people can see the
article as well
so if you want to go a little high u.s
diplomats spies and defense officials
have reported serious symptoms and some
within the past few weeks
there are more than 330 incidents of
unexplained brain injury known as havana
syndrome among u.s diplomats spies and
defense officials
some of them within the past few weeks
it has been reported the new york times
said three cia officers had been
had reported serious symptoms since
december following overseas assignments
requiring outpatient treatment at the
walter reed military hospital in
washington
one episode was within the last two
weeks the reported number of cases is
about 70 more than have previously been
acknowledged mark zedd
who represents some former uh official
afflicted by havana syndrome said he had
been
contracted by more people who believed
they had been affected by the numbers
are definitely increasing he said the
u.s officials confirmed that there are
continue to be fresh cases under review
that have caution
that the publicity given to previous
havana syndrome kids are okay
so go to the lord to see what else is
down there and anything on them down
there go go little lord the evidence for
microwave effects
of the type of categorizes havana
syndrome is exceedingly weak
rolfer wrote a foreign policy no
proponent of the idea has outlined how
the weapon
would actually work no evidence has been
offered that a such a weapon has been
developed by any nation extraordinary
claims
required extraordinary evidence and no
evidence has been offered to support the
existence of
this mysterious weapon okay interesting
you think these weapons are being used
so there's two things in this article
here one is you've got
a bunch of very professional people
being examined at walter reed by some
very good doctors
that say something definitely happened
to me the second half of this article is
the evidence for a microwave weapon is
not there so okay so maybe it's not a
microwave weapon
but the point is there's something going
on that is a
different form of of device or
technology or maybe it's just
you know the um remember the uh can i
pull up the fox news story you had a
couple guys in russia
um that died when you know kgb
operatives just sprayed them with uh
you know polonium plutonium that's um
atomized and gave them radiation
sickness and killed them
over time so these folks are talking
about havana syndrome
i think there's people there that are
really sick i think it's not a
coincidence that it happened at a
government building
is it a microwave weapon i don't know
but these people got really really sick
and i think there's advancing
technologies out there in the spike
community to kind of neutralize each
other
why is it called the havana syndrome
because it was at the
the u.s um was it the
embassy outpost or the intelligence
building in cuba
in cuba havana's in cuba which is south
of the west i've been there
right which is you ever been to south
america i've never no i've not been
there okay
stand corrected how far is that key west
from
90 miles there you go welcome to florida
republic
republican and democratic lawmakers are
demanding answers about who is
responsible for growing
consensus of experts believed our target
attacks on u.s diplomat sky can you pay
attention to pull that out please
uh and national security officials using
pulse microwave energy that many now
believe
was used as a weapon to harm american
citizens in december 2017 i made
uh which now is kind of the fateful trip
to moscow explained
marca a 26 year old veteran of the cia
who was
forced to retire as a cia's official for
clandestine
operations in europe after suffering a
mysterious traumatic brain injury and
debilitating side effects
following a trip to moscow 2017. go to
the lord to see what else he says
keep going keep going i woke up in the
middle of the night with an incredible
uh a case of vertigo of uh 10 10 what is
that how do you pronounce that tom
tinnitus tonight which is ringing in the
ears i was falling over i was nauseated
there was no mistake that something
really really terrifying happened that
night in moscow i had been in
afghanistan and i spent some time in
iraq the this was the most terrifying
experience of my life
okay and it go up see if he says
anything else as you go lower the sea
evidence was a
marriott nero tempestu when he was
attacked this case of some of the
symptoms described by 40 diplomats in
havana
serving at the u.s embassy and dozens of
u.s temple maps serving in china who in
2016 began experiencing
extreme vertical nausea sometimes
followed by a loud piercing sound that
experts now believe was a result of
directed
radio frequency energy in the form of
microwave
and by the way this is not a republican
thing or a democratic thing both cnn and
fox were talking about it
and both democrats and republicans are
saying can we look into this
i think uh there's three main points
here just to
to break this down number one is russia
shady
yes number two does russia do things to
poison people
and do havana like syndrome episodes
yes number three remember the i remember
in the 80s my mom would say don't stand
in front of the microwave
boom that's the final thing maybe you
shouldn't stand in front of the
microwave i don't know how this is
happening
but you put your cup of coffee in there
you keep it moving you show you know
like for instance
and they're all mounted above your other
friend close to your head
my friend caroline just warmed up this
tea i don't know i'm not feeling so good
right now but
hopefully we're all right maybe she did
a service but i think isn't the point
here russia does some shady ass and
everything all right you know anything
is that what like this ass stands for
yeah exactly method of uh
weapons have changed dramatically man
like the days of uh you know
when i was speaking to uh uh mike baker
i said mike how do you change this up he
said
change the method of a military budget
that we have we're spending too much
money on weapons that you're not going
to use for war you're just not going to
use for war we have to spend more money
of our budget say trillion dollars of
our budget needs to be spent towards
like uh uh bio warfare intelligence
learning about these types of attacks
that are happening you know the
cyber warfare we're not prepared for
that that's kind of what he was talking
about so
i don't know it's it makes you maybe
fund a lab in wuhan that could
work on a virus it could be oh you see
what he did there okay
you said you just 11 minutes ago said
conspiracy jfk and you went to a
different direction and then you just
dropped something like that
you went there no no no it is conspiracy
but the point is have you been to one
i have not been able to know i've been
in havana not foreign
i love the wet market have you ever had
raw chipmunk man tasty
the um no the point is
let's assume there's no lab in wuhan and
nothing like there but the point is
do you think governments have labs that
are experimenting with biological agents
that could debilitate
us do you think u.s yes i think they all
do i think everybody is
i think they're all playing in these new
realms exactly what pat says
you know another aircraft carrier
another battleship another
you know you know nuclear rocket that's
not going to be launched
oh god we hope uh but then what are they
doing on the other side
you know how do you handle big
populations poisons
biological agents you know interference
with power grids
i mean and that's the other thing what
are they investing in they're investing
things that don't make people sick
but they're looking at things how do we
hack in and shut down power grids
and like somebody has hacked in and shut
down part of a gasoline operation
system that disrupted part of the east
coast of the united states for uh
energy transport yep that's right i
think you hit the nail on the head pat
that you know things have changed so
warfare will need to change rather than
tanks maybe you need microwaves or
biological warfare
things have changed significantly since
you were in the army yeah dramatically
oh yeah dramatically i think one
investing what what direction you make
your investments in but also realizing
that as you get bigger
you may not even know like a 17 year old
hacker may be an enemy of yours
it's who you offend right now and you
got to be so careful with who you offend
right now there are so many
though you may be a 40 year old guy
who's done well for yourself financially
you could offend the wrong person that
knows certain ways to hack into certain
things and makes your life a living hell
it's a completely different ballgame
today
so it's not just russia or china
the war many people may be playing as a
different war than the government may be
playing it's a complete different game
today
well very very different game being
played today with that being said
um it's like that's like let me put it
through this way let me put it through
this way
say you know how to do jiu jitsu
unboxing mma we go in the street fight
you can 99.9 percent of people they go
out a guy comes up to you at the bar
pushes you punches you in the face you
drop him and next thing he's on the
floor crying and you take out three of
his friends
that makes good for a good video goes
viral on youtube takes
off right but say you do that to an 18
year old kid and you talk trash to him
and you're the ufc mma guy you know how
to fight
that guy ends up following you he finds
out who you are he finds details about
you
and he makes your life a living hell and
you're wondering what the hell happened
the ufc the jiu jitsu stuff doesn't
matter today just like
tanks weapons m16s f
these things don't matter with today's
war it's
just the reality of it it's a very
low-key china method of attacking versus
the look how powerful we are attacking
it's very different dana white would be
very upset to hear that
it's just the truth though yeah it's
very but here's the thing who the hell
is going to buy a pay-per-view of two
hackers going
going out against each other hello you
know
17 year old from you know toledo's well
pat you should apologize to the hackers
right now
i'd like on behalf of this oh you're
right you're right
don't look at us we're nice people check
this out your best interest in mind
going back to what i was talking about
charlie wilson's war
you know they figured out one thing the
afghans did not have better technology
than the russians or russians did but
they figured out one thing if we could
give them
basic stinger all stinger is a simple
little
you know missiles you know you might
call it a bazooka but
it was just a missile and it shot down
helicopters and airplanes so it was very
it was not huge secret super
star wars spy tech it was just let's
just give them an ability to
hide behind the rocks because they
didn't march around in big groups or big
battalions like the russians did
so five afghans could be behind a rock
and knock down a helicopter and that's
how they eventually chased
russia out of it it was low-tech and it
was asymmetrical you fight this way we
fight this way so it's asymmetrical
and now it's a digital war it's an
economic war
there the war is being fought so
differently
it's it's not about war armaments and
actually if we break into a conventional
giant conventional bombing and assault
war it's really
you're stepping backwards with somebody
that's not the way
the next war be fought if it happens to
be china i don't disagree by the way
caleb box maybe
maybe with my guy maybe i would just
gave 50 bucks and he said if there's
another atom in the galaxy we are all
doomed that's
oh caleb yeah he said that about you
okay okay
i remember that caleb okay so next
conversation next topic is
yes we can't hear you buddy turn on
that's that's kai's buddy by the way
one thing that i think is interesting as
well as as war now
it's not nations against nations it
could be one rogue osama bin laden
versus
a country or this and the other and also
even
going back to the korean war is in some
ways
you can win by just not losing or just
not giving up like the north korea did
in vietnam as well where they didn't win
they just tired out
to where america then lost interest in
the war and that led to america losing
so
there's different ways of winning wars
and especially now when it's not a whole
nation versus a whole nation
it's a lot different so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye